[Musique]
mois de janvier c'est la tradition se
souhaite la bonne année avec des voeux
alors ya plusieurs manières de le faire
par sms ou par mail mais le meilleur
moyen c'est quand même de recevoir une
jolie carte
mélanie vous allez nous donner quelques
idées oui un moyen là aussi très
personnelle de présenter ses voeux alors
elle est très simple la carte que j'ai
fait ça avec dès tout petit renne
l'idéel ssl d'andria sur au droit ou
venir alors ça faire dès l'âge de 3 ans
et en plus ça demande très peu de
matériel regarder il faut de la peinture
un tube de colle des feutres un rouge et
un noah et des feuilles de format a4 de
papier légèrement cartonné moi j'ai
choisi des teintes marron à une foncé et
une bien plus claire une première étape
le découpage
j'ai choisi de fermer petit renne sur la
feuille à la plus claire je plie la
feuille a4 en deux on va voir les étapes
et je découpe là avec les mains il n'y a
pas besoin de ciseaux c'est pour ça
qu'on peut faire tout petit pour que ça
coûte bien par contre il faut bien
appuyé sur la pliure et je collerais
plus tard cette découpe sur la feuille
marron donc pour la rendre plus petit
là aussi je découpe les bords pas de
taille précise c'est vous qui choisissez
et on passe ensuite à la partie de plus
amusante et oui parce qu'on arrive au
moment où on va mettre les doigts dans
la peinture alors si vous avez de la
peinture marron prenez-la telquel moi je
fumais petite popote avec un mon index
jeu gauche pardon j'ai pris un petit peu
de peinture et si on m'a fait on va vous
le voyez j'ai fait quatre tâches plutôt
vers le haut alors vous pouvez faire
plus grosse ou pas en fonction des
doigts que vous de la taille de vos
doigts leur attention c'est de la
peinture ça peut ça peut glisser faux
fait pouet retrait précis en plus après
pardon vous la mettez de côté pour
laisser sécher vous prenez la feuille
marron je vais rattraper ça va un peu
plus vite vous la payer en deux pour
former la carte vous mettez de la colle
sur la première page et kohl et lé petit
renne dessus et pour terminer bien sûr
vous inscrivez dessus la nouvelle année
2018 et pourquoi pas un petit mot alors
les rênes comment ce qu'on les fait du
coup c'est la toute dernière étape parce
que vous avez déjà fait des petits
dessins et vous allez prendre avec votre
feutre noir dessiné les bois et les yeux
puis le petit stylo rouge va servir à
faire un petit rond qui fera là et selon
vos envies il est également possible de
faire d'autres formes alors là on va les
montres et ben je vais s'est montrée
mélanie à l'écran vous avez également
réalisé un sapin et un bonhomme de neige
voilà l oasis avec les doigts donc
chacun peut laisser libre cours à sa
créativité merci en tout cas mélanie et
meilleurs voeux pour cette année 2018 si
on passe